all right I
goty come to
me where are you you know where I
am how am I supposed to get there the
old Irish way you're still Irish aren't
you I'm Irish enough
honey
[Music]
am thought you were off
of off it being a
crutch
but I'll sip whiskey and stare at the
stars with
you oh thank
you I want you to take me on a
date a date
huh and
date with
dinner maybe we can go to that music
festival after all Beth I'm way too
tired to analyze exactly what it is that
you want but I know it ain't a date it's
no
test just a
date Lord knows you can afford it been
wearing the same three pairs of jeans
and jacket for a [__]
decade yeah probably got more money than
me no money is the one thing I don't
have you get paid every week don't you m
so what do you spend your money
on you're keeping a sweet little place
in town for Saturday nights Jesus Christ
why is it that your mind always stops
the first thing that you should never do
what's wrong with that I was a man I'd
buy an apartment complex and I'd fill it
with bucks and little bunnies I'd start
on the first floor Friday and end up on
the roof by
Sunday I'm serious
serous why do you spend your
money B it's a nice night let not ruin
it with the truth tell
me I spent $22,000 on my mom's headstone
stands about tall as
me
marel got the guy at at your face into
it I spent 30 on my my little brothers
his stand's a little bit taller I don't
know I guess I want him to be a little
closer to
heaven but the best money that I ever
spent was 5,000 to a Gravedigger in
foresight what did he pay him
for he dug up my
father gave me
B under from there all the way to North
Dakota throwing him out the [__]
window I remember the stories of Heaven
and Hell in
church lies a lot of
it I think Heaven's right
here so's
hell one person can be Walk in the
Clouds right next to someone enduring a
teral damnation and God is the
land don't say
it it doesn't mean anything on a roof
under stars like a bunch of [__]
hippies hey tell
me tell me when it saves
me
okay I want
[Music]
that